ah yes and I'm a communist so I think
that that [ __ ] you know
I think that that's great I think that
everyone should have the most equal
amount of money dude
I think that it should be about uh what
do you call it
um
what do you call it
um it should be like Russia are they
Communists I don't know but we come here
to learn we don't come here to learn we
come here to talk about the hard-hitting
issues like pants
um so yeah what's going on over I
haven't heard about Russia in a long
time they still fighting the media will
do some [ __ ] they'll be hanging out
having a good time talking about some
[ __ ] and then they'll just like be like
all right dude we'll get back to you on
like some real big [ __ ] happens but
they're still fighting over there that's
the thing about war
I'll tell you right now
here's here's a [ __ ] hot take
War
takes too long
it takes too long
do it
better and way quicker
war is like when I have to go to Target
with my wife
and you know because she's like let's go
I think I'm Gonna Make You the executive
decision that you're going to come and
we're all going to go as a family and
I'm like all right you know I'm like the
[ __ ] Secretary of State or whatever
like I guess if that's really what you
want to do Mrs president Madam president
and then we go to the [ __ ]
um I'm like the Donald Rumsfeld or
whatever no he's the [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] I don't know but like I don't know
much about the government but you know
what I mean I'm trying to paint a
picture and then we go and then I'm just
like she's like looking at dresses and
[ __ ] and it's like this is Target you
look at pots and pans and maybe like a
[ __ ] nose hair clipper
but she's like look at this cute little
pumpkin thing with the straw on it
we should get it for Halloween and I'm
like it's August 5th
but I love it right she's my angel and I
want her to be happy and I want her to
be happy at the [ __ ]
uh
Halloween dude and all the holidays
so it's like okay and yes our Christmas
tree's still up it's January 9th
um what is it January uh ninth
he gets it right on the money folks but
uh he's a mental calendar dude he's a
he's the human calendar step right up
step right
it's the human calendar
he'll guess what day it is all right
or you'll win a stuffed toy
hello sir hi fella
what day is it January 9th oh it is yeah
yeah so get out of here you don't get a
stuffed toy
[Music]
um like to guess your weight [ __ ] you
know what I mean explaining it too much
but uh yeah dude work takes too long man
it's like
Russia versus Ukraine
women
hey Russia you're too big big
how you not winning
what's it been like eight months
come on man you're not good at War
like
America we got all the Manpower when we
went to in [ __ ] in remember how long
it took when we were in Iraq how are we
not winning dude that took what how long
was that war
remember the first day we were bombing
the [ __ ] out of all all of them and it's
like oh [ __ ] we're winning dude they
called it shock and awe
oh we're winning and then it just kept
going and going like them [ __ ] rides
at Target like the [ __ ] aisles just
all of a sudden the soldiers are in the
goddamn aisle with the what's her name
Daisy Fuentes uh clothing line or
whatever the [ __ ]
and the soldiers are like how the [ __ ]
did we get in here I didn't even know
Daisy Fuentes had a clothing line
another guy's like that's actually how
she makes most her money most people
think she was a model minimum
no no she has a [ __ ] dig it's also a
calls she's really
she's really in the [ __ ] good at the
trench
she she does a lot of leggings and moms
moms love her [ __ ]
yeah
so does JLo I don't know if you know
that no I know about JLo
yeah so Sergeant hey Sergeant [ __ ]
Sergeant Swanson you know about JLo I do
yeah
oh they got he stood up when he was
talking about J.Lo they got him oh you
got me
congratulations
[Music]